welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information about which of the
forgotten x-men kevin feige considers
worth saving
and which he's just gonna let fade from
existence
i'm eric voss here with me is inside
marvel co-host first time on big
question jessica clement
hi very nervous but i think we'll answer
today's question of what
kevin feige finds it's like what stays
fresh in people's minds by testing it
with me today because these movies are
old
they are very old this is a a stroll
down memory lane
set to either time in a bottle or the
eurythmic sweet dreams because evan
peters quicksilver folks he just showed
up in wanda vision he's in the mcu now
the hell is going on uh it seems like
this is the first ever crossover in the
mcu by a fox x-men character
but maybe you're watching this after a
future one division episode
has come out and clarified what this
cameo means maybe it's something else
maybe other x-men characters have
cameoed but
no matter what this question remains
which of the fox x-men movies are
essential
what movies do we need to have watched
and what characters and plot details
could feige be bringing into the mcu
very important
questions and also great summarizing for
anyone that has not watched a single
x-men movie
we're going to tell you the ones that
are important to watch
i mean the the short answer is all of
them are important to watch but we know
not all of you are obsessive re-watchers
we're going to give you kind of a
shorthand of how to
how to think about this franchise
because it appears certain details are
going to be
important there are 13 of these movies
and not all of them are essential not
all of them are going to get the
some are gonna have to wait in line
before we consider them to be important
uh these movies span from the first
x-men that came out 2000 to
the new mutants that came out last year
they're all kind of connected in some
way
and now this franchise in a way lives on
a wan division
in evan peters marvel head kevin feige
actually was an associate producer on
that first x-men film that's how he got
started in the superhero genre
so this man has been intimately involved
with that franchise he's a lot of
thoughts on what he wants to do
with all these little toys all right so
we're going to talk about everything you
need to know from these movies
and based on what a vision which x-men
feige might save in which you might you
know just reboot
and a spoiler warning for all of these
movies we're not going to go through
what happens
at the end of each plot they're still
worth watching but we're gonna give you
a basic overview and which characters
appear in it oh and oh by the way before
we begin i
am wearing a shirt that you can get at
new rockstar's official merch store new
rockstarsmerch.com there's a couple
different shirts that we have they're
all really great designs
they fit really well and it's a way you
can support this channel directly
in addition to shirts we got like
hoodies jackets underwear socks this hat
that i like wear all the time
so if you want to pull a bucky or cap
and have a simple costume that no one
will recognize you and just put on a
ball cap get one of these it's great all
right jessica let's go back to the
beginning
the x-men the first x-men in the year
2000.
you remember this plot don't you uh
wolverine joins professor x's x-men to
stop magneto's brotherhood of mutants
from converting world leaders into
mutants which jessica can we can we say
this is not that horrible of a plot by
magneto he's just trying to teach the
world empathy
also this is the first one so it's like
they're gonna they're gonna come in a
little heavy but they're also
to come in with like we could make a
million spin-offs
so i think it is as a writer's
standpoint they came in with a
enough and then also this makes sense
yeah i mean compared to
every other superhero movie like the
stakes of this
it's like oh so the un's just gonna get
turned into mutants
i guess the fear is that they would have
ended up like senator kelly and turn
into a jellyfish and just like explode
in the water
a puddle so maybe they die i think that
was the real stakes of it but you know
from the outset
you could argue that's what makes
magneto such a great character is he
kind of has this noble
cause of uh you can understand where
he's coming from he was a kid who
survived auschwitz
so like you kind of see his side of it
we did get that intro obviously of him
and auschwitz and like him
like kind of do in the middle and it was
very sad but i still was like i don't
really like this man but i see his
history and it is bad it wasn't until
which we'll get into later but first
class where i was like oh
i see where he's coming from this i was
still like oh he's obviously the villain
but like in first class i was like whose
side would i be on the timeline of this
movie
uh it was said not too distant future it
was later defined to be around 2003 it
was set right before the second movie
what do you remember this movie what do
you think fans should take away from
this movie jessica
okay from a fan that hasn't seen this
movie in a long time
as a fan i've seen this movie a long
time anna pacquiao was obviously rogue
was very important but she doesn't
really stay
but i think rogue was very important in
this wolverine's obviously very
important magneto is
super important i really held on to the
point of colossus showing up but i think
that's because i like colossus in the
comic books that i was like oh
we're gonna see more of this person so i
think those even if they were like such
small parts
they were still very important to be
like they're gonna show up
just you wait obviously james mars in a
cyclops was super important and jean
grey because that relationship we were
like oh
where did this start and we had a bunch
of questions about jean grey that we
get into later on yeah so i think the
mutants really held on to me
a lot of great action in this one you
could say this is one of the earliest
like
modern superhero movies that felt pretty
cool i mean their costumes were goofy
they were wearing black tight leather
they couldn't move around it didn't make
sense wasn't practical
that scene where rogue basically killed
wolverine in her sleep or in his sleep
that was very
i loved it i was here for how many times
has wolverine died like let's talk about
that
oh so many times how many times
[Applause]
it was just so funny because he dies so
many times in this franchise
and at that moment when we first saw
this movie we were like oh
shoot like he can die and then later on
you're like
okay he can't really die and uh this
movie introduced something that if
you're re-watching the x-men movies
you see all over the place the mystique
yellow eyes
trope a character who you think is one
character they flash their eyes
in this movie it was senator kelly at
the end of the movie but then they
started doing it
crazily throughout the series everyone
at some point is a big mistake
how else are you going to tell their a
person or mystique you got to you got to
put some just got to tell them
yeah you can to do it at the end of the
day this movie
of the x-men franchise yes essential
this is essential if you watch any of
them you do have to watch this one you
can check it out it's wonderful
uh and i would say the same for x2 x-men
united
so the plot of this one after a failed
white house assassination attempt
colonel stryker played by the amazing
brian cox
detains professor x and a couple other
students from the x-mansion
uh his plan to use cerebro through uh
mind control via his son jason striker
inside charles xavier's brain
to target all mutants and to kill them
so the x-men have to team up with
magneto escape from prison
on this rescue mission at the weapon x
space at alkali
lake so this is all set in 2003 shortly
after the first x-men movie
and yeah this is for me one of my
favorite x-men movies i just think that
opening sequence is so great in the
white house
it catches you right away the pacing's
great the humor is great
um and i just love it very very
essential one and this one brings in
another goofy trope from the x-men
franchise i love where professor x
rolls in and freezes the room they do
this constantly
professor x will just randomly show up
in a movie and everyone's just like
oh right this is the thing that happens
i love it
is it weird i didn't think it was weird
that he can do that i don't think it's
weird
but they just keep doing it it comes
back in a lot of them
he's cool as well the third movie on our
watch list is x-men the last stand it
came out in 2006 so the plot of this one
sorry it's kind of like an adaptation of
the dark phoenix saga
jean grey returns back from the dead
possessed by the phoenix entity but
meanwhile
they didn't really go full into the dark
phoenix saga because
really they started to adapt josh
sweden's cure storyline from the x-men
comics
so a war is breaking out over this
mutant cure uh vaccine
uh between the x-men and the brotherhood
and uh um
magneto's forces have grown to like
dozens hundreds of mutants
uh and it's an insane movie uh it's the
main cast returning but there's like a
ton of uh mutants there's too many
mutants in this
in this there's way too many for you to
be like let's clock
every single person yeah i would say
this one is not
essential oh it's so fun though
it's so it's it is fun if you want to
watch it go for it
it's not essential you don't even see it
there's very fun parts
there's very fun parts and i was jumping
into the juggernaut ones
the introduction of the juggernaut is
one of my favorite parts
of just juggernaut chasing shadow cat
through that facility is awesome
yes yes please watch it also
kelsey grammer as the beast is my
favorite thing in the world
of it's okay i get that it's not
important
but the reason i say this is not
essential is because the entire
events of this movie kind of get erased
and retconned by later movies
um and that includes the deaths of a lot
of characters i won't say everyone who
dies
but uh charles appears to die early on
in this movie
but at the very end he kind of reawakens
in uh
moira mctaggart's coma patient it's not
really explained what's going on there
i'm spoiling it for you because i don't
think this movie is essential to watch
i'm sorry
don't spoil it don't spoil it soiled it
so i have it oh because i think it's
still fun
look i still think it's fun also i guess
you could still use it if you
saw dark phoenix it might be good i
guess chronologically
it doesn't add up but like watching this
and then seeing dark phoenix i was like
oh i know what's happening in dark
phoenix because i know what happened
in x-men last stand but or you could
just read chris claremont's dark phoenix
saga and the
80s way better can
but it is fun okay go listen to boss
but i think it's it's very fun
i'm very i'm here for it hey look every
movie that we mentioned
at the end of the day probably worth
checking out if you have the time we're
just giving you the list of the
ascension there's shade
movies have to not be essential jessica
for others to be essential but let's
move right along to the next movie on
our list x-men origins
wolverine it came out in 2009 so this is
a wolverine origin story it follows
james hallett
throughout american history he fought in
pretty much every american war
uh alongside his buddy sabertooth played
by liam schreiber
they joined weapon x he they end up
turning on each other
it ends with him fighting deadpool uh
but really uh a mix of a bunch of other
members of weapon next to it died
a pool of them a dead pool
i love them not the right version of the
character his mouth gets uh smushed over
so he can't talk uh their merc with the
mouth they took his mouth away
it makes no sense uh which you've if
you've watched the deadpool movies you
know
why this is so weird this ends with a
horribly dh patrick stewart
walking up as professor x oh god it was
really stupid it's
pretty bad the timeline of this movie
starts in 1845 and then it jumps ahead
through different wars so we see the
1860s and 1940s uh and then 1973 in
vietnam that's when uh
uh striker finds them and then uh years
later in 1979 is when the rest of the
movie takes place
so it's supposed to be like in the 70s
general era this again very much so i
would say
is not essential to watch
and again it's just these events were
completely erased from the timeline so
that even the franchise wants you to
forget about them
is it worth watching for will i am
absolutely also it's like the
introduction to the blob which is very
fun
for people that read the comics it's
really fun to just see these like oh
i know who this is right off the bat did
you just call me
blob i understood that reference but it
definitely
was skip on past that one um so at this
point
in the late 2000s the x-men franchise
was in
a weird place
what they did is they brought in matthew
vaughn to reboot it
do a soft reboot though x-men first
class
charles xavier eric lyncher meet in the
60s and they assemble a team
to fight sebastian shaw's hellfire club
and it ties in with the cuban missile
crisis
so the cast of this one uh now charles
xavier is played by james mcavoy magneto
is played by michael fassbender mystique
is played by jennifer lawrence though
there is a moment where she shape-shifts
into an older woman to try to
entice uh eric lyncher and that older
woman
is rebecca romain perfection morrow
mctaggart is played by rose byrne hank
mccoy is now played by nicholas holt
sebastian shaw the great kevin bacon
emma frost in this movie is played by
the not so great january jones
havoc is played by lucas till and
there's a bunch of uh younger mutants
who are brought in they got like banshee
they got uh riptide angel darwin
who's one of the best mutants killed um
oh i mean no spoilers wait can we spoil
it oh yeah we won't say everything
immediately immediately
had maybe 30 seconds in the movie and
they straight up were like you want to
turn into a half
rock half volcano human man and just
collapse
what you say now one of the best parts
of this movie
uh we're uh spoiler warning for again
for this movie wolverine
cameos in it as one of the like it says
yourself go get yourself
yeah and they just walk away they go
okay cool so
absolutely this one is essential it's
one of the best of this franchise it's
so good
uh because it starts to explore this
question of how would the x-men have
intersected with u.s history
and it is kind of like what we grew up
watching the x-men animated series it
feels fresh
feels exciting it's funny it has a good
uh self-awareness to it
i love so much about this movie i can't
recommend it enough
it is the best it's my favorite there's
so much going on that definitely
i feel like they're gonna make so many
callbacks to so many
like going in the future not already
that they've done
but i feel like there's gonna be like oh
remember this and we have to talk about
it
yourself now the next x-men movie to
come out was called
the wolverine that came out in 2013.
this was james mangold's
movie that was supposed to follow x-men
origins of wolverine
uh but this was just a solo mission that
was set in japan
uh so really the plot of this one is it
opens with wolverine saving a japanese
man from an atomic bomb exploding during
world war ii
and years later he gets a chance to kind
of trade in his immortality
uh but it leads to this pretty cool plot
uh
where it's all set in japan and he
fights against the yakuza
he ends up having to fight the uh
adamantium silver samurai there's a fun
twist with that
uh i'd recommend watching this one now
this movie seemed like it was completely
unrelated to the fox
x-men uh canonical timeline but
at the very end in the post-credits
scene wouldn't you know it patrick
stewart charles xavier
and ian mckellen uh oh magneto
showing up at an airport there is a tv
screen
that uh says trask industries is working
on
some sentinel technology that was all
meant to set up days of future past so
they they forced this whole stupid scene
in there
getting loser we're going shopping but
the movie is pretty good
i would just say uh is it essential
kinda i would say watch it it's good
it's just for timeline purposes and
canon purposes
it's not that important to watch this is
the only one i think i feel strong like
no but i also think when i watched it i
took it out of the equation
i was like oh it's just like a really
cool movie now the next title on our
list
x-men days of future past 2014.
so the plot of this one to prevent a
post-apocalyptic future
that uh features all the original x-men
cast coming back
wolverine goes back in time to the 70s
to stop mystique from killing trask
that would you know because if he dies
then all of his sentinel research is
going to lead to this
like uh it's a mystique being caught and
they take mystique's dna
and they turn the sentinels into
replicating things that can kill any
mutant whatever
uh so to prevent that they have to they
have to turn her back to the good side
and when wolverine goes back in time
they use a kitty pry to blast his
consciousness back in time to his
younger body
it's a different kind of time travel uh
and he gets to hang out with all the
first class era characters
so they kind of like restore all the
continuity problems
in the franchise in this really cool way
so the cast
is massive and insane it's fun so the
timeline the post-apocalyptic future i
love this is 2023.
that's what everything's [ __ ] two more
years so they go back 50 years earlier
uh
in 1973 and the final scene is set in
that restored 2003.
so i love this movie because it's one of
the smartest versions of time travel
that we've seen in the superhero movie
i think it's much well structured than
even avengers end game
uh because the time travel logic within
the movie for the most part until the
very end
is pretty clean and it's fun to see a
character go
like do a slaughterhouse five version of
time travel where it's just your
consciousness through your body
uh they don't really do that a lot in
movies and i love seeing it in this film
this movie
i like that you said yes is it essential
did you say yes because of the time
travel
i think it is essential because it
involves the first class uh characters
it brings in evan peters quicksilver
which
obviously this guy's important i
completely forgot i was like oh yeah i
guess
don't you forget it it's one of the i
would say it's of the half
of them that are absolutely essential to
watch also so for those that didn't read
the comics which is completely fine
the fact that magneto and quicksilver
are related and they talk about it in
this and they'll probably bring it up
eventually again
when they bring up wanda and juan
division but i get the take jessica that
you weren't a huge fan of this movie no
no no i liked it i just don't know it
was important
stop no i told you i like the young
x-men it's like the baby looney tunes
for me i get really into it
i love anytime you put things as young
like when you're like oh we're going to
do golden girls but they're like
24. i'm like okay i'm gonna watch it you
need to hashtag release the muppet baby
stock
muffin babies i couldn't they're all
great it's great and i think
you could watch this if you don't watch
this one you have to watch uh the last
stand in x-men origins
so if you watch this one you never have
to think about the last standard x-men
origins yeah
so the next x-men title is deadpool i'm
touching myself tonight oh yeah
kind of adjacent to x-men but it is he
is a mutant it is part of the x-men
franchise
this is where ryan reynolds is like no
we're going to do a proper deadpool
movie
[ __ ] you slater x-men origins so in this
story
we meet mercenary wade wilson the merc
with the mouth uh he tries to cure his
cancer
by letting the weapon x turn him into a
regenerative mutant
now going under the name deadpool and he
ends up having to save his fiancee
vanessa from ajax it's kind of a lovely
rom-com
this movie is so great it's super funny
it's super meta
yeah it's it's a really really fun movie
and uh
i think you gotta see all the deadpool
movies because deadpool's coming into
the mcu so yes essential
very essential and also very funny oh my
god you're so funny
and also the fact that he just keeps
reiterating how he doesn't want to be a
part of the x-men and they're just like
come on be a part of us
no not joining your weird heaven's gate
cult so the next
x-men movie to come out came in uh came
out a couple months after deadpool x-men
apocalypse they decided to move each of
these uh this first class reboot uh
advance each one up the decades so
the first one was in the 60s the days of
future pastors in the 70s
and now this one's in 1983. but it's all
about apocalypse he's the ancient mutant
he was in the post-credits scene of days
of future past he reawakens now and he
assembles his four horsemen of the
apocalypse
to help him destroy and remake the world
and they tie in with the cold war in the
80s
to try to unleash a global nuclear war
doesn't go that way and they
use like magneto they used to combine
powers of these four henchmen
to try to like terraform the earth and
obliterate all
uh civilization this one is mostly
memorable
for another great quicksilver sequence
this time he saves all the kids from uh
the x-mansion set to the rhythmic sweet
dreams
there's also a cameo by wolverine gene
and scott go to the weapon x facility
and uh he's just happens to be there
because i think days of future past
ended with him
in the 70s in stryker's clutches but it
was another like flash of yellow eyes so
it's mystique but that was never
explained
it just he's just back with that weapon
x at that point got it what are your
thoughts on this movie jessica do you
think it's essential
the only part i would think is essential
is isn't this where professor x
basically
destroys apocalypse and the astral plane
yeah there is an astral plane battle
that's right and that's how he loses his
hair
why so the astral plane is going to be
important going on because
not only can people that can read minds
go through it but
i said magicians but david copperfield
also can go through there
you're on the moon no but magic can go
on there i don't think it's essentially
the astral plane where scarlet witch
like lands in some of the comics it's a
different plane but she can still go oh
yeah and doctor strange goes to that
doctor strange goes to the so i think
it's essential not essential for like
you i don't think you need to watch the
entire movie to be like
the astral plane but i think like that
part itself
um is very important to take away
because you could be like if they ever
reference it again and you're like
when did they ever reference that it was
an x-men apocalypse i would say at the
end of the day though this movie is not
essential to watch if you were to skip
this one you'd be okay but that scene
is very fun he's gonna be okay you will
be okay but you're missing out on some
cinematic
art now the next movie in the x-men
franchise to come out was
logan this was considered to be the
third wolverine solo film
this is directed by james mangled once
again and to me this is my favorite
x-men movie
uh this is basically just a simple
western
it's uh loosely adapted from the old man
logan comics but this one old retired
beaten down logan
is taking care of an elderly charles
xavier who is not
stable and he meets a young runaway x-23
uh laura and he has to drive her to the
canadian border to
uh get her away from people who want to
do her ill will
they're kind of doing some weapon x
stuff the timeline of this is
fascinating so this is set
in the year 2029 it's in the revised
timeline
from the present day at the end of days
of future past but it's still implied
that
things still crumble into
post-apocalyptic status
no matter what you do but there's like a
fascinating hinted backstory that around
2014 in that timeline mutants started to
die off mysteriously they started to go
extinct
it was revealed that there's some kind
of toxin in the food and water supply
but there was a deadly psionic seizure
by charles xavier that killed off most
of the x-men in this movie
it's so dark but it's so beautiful it's
it was one of my favorite movies that
year i think it should have won an oscar
it was so incredible i did not know this
movie touched you so much oh
i love it i love it and it looks like
it's the only one i cried in
i cried at the end because i was like
that's a good ending so
essential yeah i actually think it is
um not just for how great of a movie it
is
um and how great all the performances
are but there are some important tie-ins
with the x-men franchise going forward
like the character x23 and like what
they were doing with x23
and what we'll talk about that at the
end when we recap all the characters we
think are coming back but you like this
one jessica you think it was
yeah i liked logan i it
i like logan i like logan i'll say that
i still want to see an
i want to see a true old man logan movie
in the emcee
because that comic is like one of the
most [ __ ] up comics you know
hugh jackman is so tired he's so tired
he wants to sing and dance in movies
instead
but they did like and all these random
spliced mutant children are just now
gone
they're like we haven't seen them so
it's like they could be showing up again
and they
or even if they don't they have that to
hold on to in the back of their pocket
they're like oh we can go back to x23
if we want she could be like a grown
woman by now or or a teenager
a young woman yeah she could be a young
woman a young grown woman
i think it's also just it's like the
grittiest you're gonna get in that
franchise
like with like real like
so you should watch it for that
perspective because this feels a lot
different than any of the other ones
then that's i think that's how i took it
i kind of didn't put it in the bunch
because i was like
it hit a little too hard well a movie
that parodied logan
was the next one on our list deadpool 2.
this came out in 2018.
uh the plot of this one is both very
simple and very complicated essentially
deadpool has to protect an
orphan uh played by julian dennison
firefist the mutant
uh who was like in this creepy culty
school uh but now he is the target
of a uh time traveling assassin cable
played by thanos
josh brolin uh and we meet a bunch of
new characters
it's pretty amazing has one of the best
endings and it's supposed to be adapted
from like the deadpool and cable comics
it's
one of the best buddy comedy comics you
can read firefist uh well he's named
firefist that's not his real name uh but
julian jensen's character domino
zacc beets is in this she can kind of
like use luck she can play the odds some
probability
to like know how to get out of tough
spots pretty cool power i love it
yukio that's shiry katsuna um and then
the x-force that deadpool puts together
so we got bedlam
terry crews shatterstar louis tan
zeitgeist
bill skarsgard peter played by rob
delaney
and then the vanisher played by spoiler
word in here
the best cameo brad pitt so stupid
so they don't last long in the movie but
it's one of the
funniest sequences ever and then as you
mentioned juggernaut shows up he's a
voice by ryan reynolds and then there's
also really funny cameo in the x-mansion
where like all those uh
x-men apocalypse characters show up
professor x b clock silver storm
and nightcrawler they're all there so uh
evan peters
versus deadpool um this one though is
set after the first years of deadpool
it's it's
kind of adjacent with the x-men timeline
it's just kind of in its own meta world
it's like a cartoon
deadpool 2 is so fun when you said
complicated until you started explaining
it i was like oh yeah i forget there's
time travel
yes and that's why it could be very
important for the mcu
is because he uses time travel and
uh we know the time variance authority
is coming up in loki so this could be
very important for what we see coming up
yeah
definitely watch deadpool 2. uh
essential
i feel like if they do bring on cables
like time travel i think they're just
gonna
like crash it in the next movie just so
it's like stop jumping through time
so our next title x-men dark phoenix
uh this poor movie stop don't feel don't
give a pity
okay i won't i'll feel nothing for it so
this one
is set in 1992 it uh it's like kind of a
redo of the dark phoenix saga
um jean grey gets possessed by the
phoenix force and she becomes a target
of
shape-shifting aliens that are not
scroll they are
de bari unfortunately this movie got
delayed and delayed
to the point of coming out months after
captain marvel
when scrolls in the marvel universe
existed so
they just felt like a copy of them ah
it's a weird movie
um really it's just the returning x-men
cast
um there's a couple other smaller uh
mutants that show up in it you don't
need to know any of their names
i'm sorry it's what i think drives me
nuts about this movie among many things
is it's set in 1992
30 years after x-men first class yet
none of the characters from that movie
age nicholas holt still looks just as
young
uh mystique looks just as young now you
can say mistake's a shape-shifter
whatever but
this whole beast doesn't have like a
regenerative age you know that doesn't
make any sense that these things they
couldn't
say grammar it's bizarre i guess that
doesn't answer but yeah but
mystique doesn't she doesn't really age
she stays young forever
i think a lot of us just felt like why
does the movie need to exist
and in fairness i think it was like the
whole studio just kind of bailed on it
because at that point
boxes had been bought out by disney and
i think the whole studio was like well
disney's just gonna reboot all these
characters anyway
let's not put any effort into promoting
this movie
or or doing reshoots or making it any
good so
i would say only because the studio
seemed to feel this way
it is not essential to watch you can
totally skip dark phoenix
the last title we'll talk about the new
mutants to come out it came out this
year so
in this movie it's basically like young
mutants are in this psychiatric facility
and they're battling their demons it's
kind of creepy it's kind of cool
the villain is kind of a manifestation
of mirage's power the
demon bear she kind of forces everybody
to confront their inner demons in a way
and in her case it's the demon bear but
then magic's a little sidekick lockheed
uh this little dragon thing floats
around with cider it's pretty cool it's
cool character
so what's interesting about the timeline
of this movie it is set
in the x-men franchise um because this
facility that they're in
spoiler warning is being run by the
essex corporation the
the suitcase people from the end of the
post-credits scene of x-men apocalypse
so uh it is part of that operation but
it would be decades later because
uh danny is told that there is a next
step that would lead to
these young mutants being turned into
weapons and she's his
vision of what that would be and it's
the facility shown in logan
a movie set in 2029 so new mutants must
be set
shortly before logan is maybe 2028 or
2029
so over 40 years after that scene in
x-men apocalypse is the movie necessary
then
no i don't think so evan peters not in
it i don't know if any of these
characters will get
salvaged for the mcu so let's wrap up
here
by talking about which of these
characters jessica we think
will have uh second lives these actors
could come back in the mcu
so right now it's it looks like
quicksilver evan peters in some form
is in the mcu we've gotten confirmation
that deadpool ryan reynolds will be in
the mcu as well they're working on that
script as we speak
but let's ask ourselves do we think
either the charles xavier's patrick
stewart or james mcavoy jessica do you
think they could show up in the mcu i
think the james mcavoy will
especially if we're doing time travel
both of the james mcavoy movies were
they did well so i think mcu would
definitely be like let's go back into
those because those were really those
people are big fans of those but patrick
stewart oh well i guess they could
but like he's dead uh and not
to be like people don't die but it's
like i also think patrick stewart's like
if i can pass let's just try to pass on
me well if they're pulling them from the
multiverse time isn't really an issue
you know they could just plop in
patrick stewart or ian mckellen from
that you know franchise and not really
trying to explain how
to give us like a clip what's hard is
that bringing in evan peters suggests
that it's going to be the younger cast
right
so maybe james mcavoy or michael
fassbender one of those folks maybe even
nicholas holt or
jennifer lawrence i doubt it i'm sorry i
don't think jennifer lawrence is gonna
come
no no one's gonna mystique is not gonna
make an appearance obviously the one
people want is hugh jackman wolverine
but what do you think jessica i think
that guy's done
i think he's done i think he's done dude
you guys he truly is so tired
go [ __ ] yourself not in the way of like
to be rude to him but he truly is like
i've spent my years as wolverine like
almost
two decades from 2000 to 2018
like and then that cameo he made in
deadpool he's like i still gotta show up
he's been such a trooper he keeps
showing back up well he didn't they used
archive footage in deadpool 2. he didn't
have to show
okay that's true
apocalypse he got in shape he had to go
shirtless and run around in the snow for
that scene
yeah he's a super nice guy but i don't
think he's gonna show up i don't think
he's gonna show up if he did
you guys can have my wallet i think x23
daphne keane
she might show up i think the way they
ended things in logan um she was pretty
cool in that movie i think the other
ones too
there was obviously a leader of that
group and i think he's gonna show up
again too
okay he had too many lines to not be a
big part you just gotta we gotta ask
ourselves
um who is adjacent to the characters
they're definitely bringing back so
they're definitely bringing back
deadpool i think we have a good chance
of seeing the deadpool version of
colossus
showing up because he was great oh he's
going he's going too and it's also
possible to see cable
uh josh brolin cable could totally show
up and it would be insane
but i think it's possible and uh
everyone else from his world naked sonic
teenage warhead
fire fist all those kids they might show
up so we could technically see colossus
still doing the x-men
like he is basically the only there's
not many x-men left
so he could definitely be bringing back
other people to that school
after deadpool 2 especially so i think
we're going to see colossus as like the
professor x and there's just a bunch of
new mutants which could be
x-23 it could be like mutants coming
back to like
just be better with their powers yes
storm uh alexandria
i think storm is going to show up in the
mcu i don't know if it's going to be
alexander's ship storm i don't know if
it's going to be ty sheridan cyclops
or cody smith mcphee's knight not to say
they were bad i just don't think fans
had the
attachment to those characters that uh
and i think they can get different names
to do different takes on those
characters in the mcu i think in the mcu
later on they're going to be like just
like a photo on the wall of respect
at like where the x-men are i think it's
gonna be like oh remember this storm
remember this guy remember this people
like that's the
homage we're gonna get the only rule
kevin feige's gonna apply
is in the case of deadpool no one else
can play deadpool than ryan reynolds
right now
you know um people would turn on it you
know
so but with uh evan peters quicksilver
obviously people have attachments to
aaron taylor johnson
but uh they're doing something clever
and meta and goofy on one division by
having evan peters play the role
so i i think they're not they are not
obligated to bring back all these fox
actors to play these parts i think
they're
gonna pick and choose and they're gonna
use it sounds like some kind of
multiverse explanation
to justify why they're bringing back
some and not others all right we're
gonna move on to some questions that
jessica's gonna answer but first we want
to thank some friends who helped us make
this episode
starting with our friends at amazon
pharmacy pill pack so take a break from
streaming something on prime video
or buying a new gadget and check out the
pharmacy section of amazon
amazon pharmacy is a super easy way to
save time and money and not have to wait
in line at the actual physical pharmacy
amazon pharmacy coordinates with your
doctor to receive your prescriptions and
then they deliver those medications
right to your door
they work with most insurance plans i'm
already buying stuff on amazon because
of convenience and easy delivery
just makes sense to do the same with
prescriptions which i don't want to
worry about running out of
let's be honest pharmacy errands usually
suck and right now
we should probably be doing everything
we can to avoid them take it off your
to-do list with
amazon pharmacy amazon prime members can
save on prescription medication when not
using insurance and get free two-day
delivery
learn more at amazon.com bigquestion
that's amazon.com slash bigquestion
amazon.com
big question you know we also want to
thank our friends at raycon for
sponsoring this video
so now more than ever we are staring at
screens unplugging yourself can be tough
one of my favorite ways to unplug is by
just putting in some
wireless raycon earbuds and listening to
something great
whether you're catching up on your
favorite news podcast binging an
audiobook powering through some
workout playlists a pair of raycons in
your ears can make
all the difference taking my new puppy
darla on walks is a nice time for me to
be compressed with some music which
sounds great in my brake
dangling tires get in your way here
raycon's coming arranged
a range of stylish colors and have a
comfortable in-ear fit they're water and
sweat resistant with bluetooth that
pairs quickly and seamlessly their six
hours of battery life means i can walk
my dog to the next county if i need to
raycon makes great sound accessible to
everyone with wireless earbuds starting
at half the price
of other premium audio brands raycon's
offering 15
off all their products for my listeners
and here's what you've got to do to get
it
go to buy recon dot com slash big
question that's
it you'll get 50 off your entire recon
order so feel free to grab a pair
and a spare that's fifteen percent off
at buy raycon dot com slash big
questions buy recon dot com slash big
questions
all right now we move on to some bite
size questions that jessica's gonna
answer for
us first our uh discord supporter flan
travolta philanthropy obviously flan
travolta i'm an idiot
uh they asked how exactly did jimmy wu
and monica rambo know so many intimate
details about the battle in
end game in one division episode five
it's not like there weirder
news camera is recording and it's just
weird to imagine thor
or any of the others sitting down with
the government to tell them
all the details what do you say to this
jessica i get where you're coming from
yeah thor might not be sitting down with
any of the government officials but i
mean there's still people
like captain america who really works
for the like the
government officials at the end of the
day carol danvers definitely would have
bruce banner would have pepper potts
definitely would have sat down with them
so they could have been just talking to
them about just what's going on
also let's not forget that in spider-man
homecoming
his suit had like an into recording
device
and so everyone could see what he was
doing there
yeah i mean i guess i object to the
assumption of the question that like why
would
like why would thor i don't imagine any
of them sitting down and tell the
government the story why wouldn't they
want to tell them about what tony stark
did about what happened with carol
danvers
and thanos and wanda maxum often like i
feel like they would want the world to
know that story
because it paints the avengers in a good
heroic light like they would just be
like [ __ ] it i'm gonna go
off doing my own thing nevermind i'm
leaving forever
that's a thor thing to do also the
satellite technology that sword has
that's using tony stark's
equipment and the drones in the sky that
are recording all the time yeah sword
loves drones they love drones i bet they
had drones like ooh what are they doing
they just flew drones well from one
division we can see all the drones
they're definitely just throwing drones
out there
they have no budget uh peppers rescue
suit has all this same technology inside
there's multiple ways that i'm sure that
sword could figure
out obviously any suit that tony stark
designed has like a webcam on it
and if uh you know any one of them wants
to share that drive with swords sword
would have a full
up close and personal video log of the
event also sword does not give a
[ __ ] i know i'm not going to say that
does not care
about privacy our next question comes
from the hero gotham deserves on discord
who asks
if the mcu and the x-men films exist in
the same multiverse
why do they have different time travel
rules in endgame versus days of future
past
well first off jessica let's remember
that like it's not confirmed to exist in
the same multiverse slash universe
yet you know we're still kind of waiting
to know exactly what evan peters cameo
means we
don't need to jump to conclusions yet to
answer your question sure avengers end
game does use what's called branch
timeline type 2
as i've defined it rules of time travel
where when you go back to the past you
break off and start a new timeline uh
days of future past use my favorite type
of time travel
consciousness displacement type seven i
believe uh time travel
blasts your mind back to your earlier
body but my response
and jessica i know you think about this
i would say the mcu already
has been pretty uh self-contradictory
about how time travel works oh
absolutely
you can well if you want a time travel
you can use the time stone to rewind or
fast forward time
or you could use the quantum realm time
vortex to travel to any point in the
past few years in quantum mechanics it's
multiple types of time travel one's
magic one science they're not the same
thing
it's super messy i would say that there
is no one sole type of time travel in
the mcu multiple types of time travel
are possible
and yeah i guess that would mean as
complicated and insane as this is
that within the mcu a branch timeline
created by the in-game time heist
could feature one character within that
timeline who uses consciousness
displacement
to mind travel back to his younger body
earlier in his life it's both can be
true uh it's comics
everything's crazy yeah that is also
true at the end of the day they do
whatever they
the hell they want in the comic books
and that's what we transferred into the
mcu and that's what gets us watching it
that's what gets my money all right we
have time for one final box scraps
question
scraps this comes from our discord
supporter
eel guy who asks what is a little thing
you didn't realize you'd miss during
covid shelter in place
for example i miss going to a karaoke
bar with friends
never thought i would hahaha so what's
something you
uh never thought you would miss that you
do miss jessica from being
sheltered in place this is such a
sad thing but like the text of people
asking me to hang out
like those texts of hey what are you
doing tonight i have not got one of
those in over a year
just not actually hanging out the text
to hang out
yeah yeah i do i don't go because i'm an
introvert
but i'm a recluse but i definitely miss
people being like hey do you want to go
get food and then i'd be like
no no i'm good
or me i mean my go-to answer is like go
into live events going to uh the movie
theater and stuff like that
but i'll get more specific for you i
miss going
waiting in line and getting movie
theater candy and popcorn
and snacks no one likes waiting at
line to get food no i do i do i like
getting to the movie theater a little
early
getting there 10 minutes early waiting
in line uh and specifically like
getting my nachos or getting whatever it
is my popcorn
because you can make movie theater style
popcorn at home you can get the same
kind of candy but it's
different it just tastes a little
different from concession stand
i get getting the food i order my food
to be ready by the time i get to the
theater
because i hate the line that you okay
first of all i got one of those
it's less embarrassing for me to order
the hot dog nachos
and a pretzel if i just do it through
the app and show up and it's ready
oh you know what i miss jessica is like
fountain drinks
uh because you can get soda from
wherever but like
fountain drinks has a higher
concentration of sugar in it because
they expect it to be watered down by ice
yeah so only certain restaurants will
actually give you a fountain drink
uh chipotle still does but a lot of
other places there they won't give you a
fountain drink and it's just not the
same you would always get found drinking
the movie theater
it's not the same as where'd you learn
that science i don't think that's real
it worked at a movie theater for a
summer and that's something they
explained they're like did you it's
gonna be more sugary
so like always put ice in it so that it
balances out and makes it get the right
flavor i've never heard of someone that
worked at the movie theater that misses
like standing in line for food at the
movies i do
it's part of the experience i love it oh
here's another thing i love about going
to movie theater afterwards when you
walk through the lobby and the other
conversations you hear
of like i said that for when i would go
see movies from new rock stars often i
have to go see them by myself because i
have to see it at weird times
i'd walk through the lobby and just kind
of eavesdrop to other people who'd be
like talking about it they're like
no no uh mysterio could totally still be
alive bro
he's totally still alive look peter
parker didn't ask is he dead you know
and i'd be like ah that will be the
video i make that's what people are
like thinking that's what they're asking
about i'm that person that be
when the movie ends i go stupid like i
lean over and be like
dumb or just like one word like you're
good
i also hate to be that nerd i hate
waiting after the credits for things so
i go home and i look up the stingers
later oh
i can't stand waiting that long and i
don't know why you don't watch the
credits of movies do you work in the
tv and film industry i know i know i'm
the worst
wait i'm so disrespectful i just don't i
want to go
let me get out of here please get me out
of here
get me out of this place well that is it
for this episode of the big question
jessica thank you so much for joining me
in this episode you can follow jessica
at lulu underscore clemens on twitter
lulu clemens everywhere else
you can follow me at ea vos follow new
rockstars send us your big questions on
discord by becoming a patron in new
rockstars at patreon.comrockstars that's
we get all of our best big questions
from our wonderful discorders
uh you can subscribe to the new
rockstars here on youtube hit that
notification bell and another quick
shout out to our friends at stereo the
app that lets
users listen in seek out topics and join
conversations about issues and ideas
that interest them
comedy pop culture supports all kinds of
topics and once you download the app you
can create an avatar and profile and
start going live yourself you can submit
audio messages voicemails to the host of
conversations to join the conversation
in real time
we go live with our interactive new
rockstars news show hosted by myself and
phil molina
on wednesdays at whimpy pacific also our
live simulcast of
inside marvel with jessica and me uh you
can we'll answer your questions in real
time we have new stereo shows every
monday wednesday and friday just go to
new rockstars to get all the details and
get notified when we're going live again
that's stereo.com
new rockstars see you next week
everybody bye
bye
[Music]
foreign